this is another kid that they're waiting
for him to explode he's got all kind of
ability nice move
two points
they do now change it they gave it to
green initially on the two then they
moved it to jones there's derozan with
his second bucket
had some fun teams and he was part of
those teams
derozan the fakes and the knockdown on
the field goal we told you they're the
best scoring bench in the nba they're
already halfway to their average
derozan
the party wasn't on the first floor was
it the penthouse jacob portal
that's just dumped right here
watch your head portal
my goodness
oh my goodness that's this dunk right
here
watch your head portal
my goodness
he just yet on yonko
here comes
[Applause]
now behind the back to free him up for
the
two oh he's in his bag
he's in his back
johnson does not have a three in this
game mcdermott's starting to rack him up
he's got 17 now derozan now has 17.
that's a vet move from a rookie
derozan gets to the spot and sticks it
again just
dribbles right to his spot
[Applause]
start of the fourth quarter and a
six-point san antonio lead white derozan
buchevich iowa and green the five for
the bulls and demar derozan looked like
a man on a mission there he cuts the
lead to four and a chance at a
three-point play the king of the fourth
and this is where the big boys come out
and play right here
derozan working on mcdermott
[Applause]
this is what he does right here
this big boy basketball
white derozan green buchevich out there
with brown it's derozan doing derozan
things in the fourth quarter oh oh
johnson got blocked by this underside of
the rim and the bulls are gonna shoot
for the lead it's derozan again oh mouse
and house
yes sir
he went right at trey jones
16 lead changes tonight
and 12 ties
derozan the pick of the fight
the master of the mid range
it's johnson under ozin
the master at work
oh let me get some butter with that roll
deepo
[Applause]
against bates dia
yes oh my goodness
oh my goodness you have to unless you
can get that still here it is right here
everything is coming up to rosen
look at that